è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj e oggi siamo tornati
sua non mi ricordo come al solito più
l'ultima volta ho fatto un episodio di
happy with me non me ne frega nulla
voglio provarci mini game green cos'è
sta roba si richiamano a caserta host
oliver cela la vittoria enorme per
sbagliare devi essere un deficit tra una
mera presa per il culo apre circo sesto
cosworth trovo tutti insieme come cazzo
trapassato lanciato a quel luogo non ce
lo stomaco qualcos'altro non lo so però
ho fatto un genocidio ragazzi cè un
pezzettino ciak che è rimasto che non so
perché però l'importante è che io abbia
lingua starving hobo cazzo è uno bosè
ragazzi di casa ceca pixel significa the
five è buono ma pixel c'è lei che mi
darebbe quella vista e cona che ciò fame
grazie lurido pezzo di merda si sa
ok per sé ma di the last crode il
ragazzo in modo più bello per salire una
succedono mai vista nemmeno più bella di
questa notte seriamente non c'è che
veramente figo ha fatto a pisa ricchezza
la società non so come ho fatto ma non
mi chiedete è morto l'importante è
quello adesso dovrei scendere con la
moneta
scendo con la moneta affetto mi sono
salvato ma per culo assurdo appello del
ceo chiari da adesso no perché dica ti
prenderei a pedate finché
e mi segue ancora alberga questo è uno
dei livelli più belli che abbia mai
giocato a fare un dottorando decente non
si sa come mai utili sono già saltate le
braccia cazzo c'ero quasi ce lo
scomparto per luca ditemelo che cazzo ne
so io no era per te stronzo cosa fai
amore gico i vecchi e pronta cosa
fassino lancia ho vinto ma che classe
riporta ha dato
[Musica]
va bene che cosa sto facendo
si sta contorcendo dal bellissimo 1
attenta poiché mentre levi scrivere
entra pure amico mi affido a questo
livello non sia tipo ascensore grazie se
tipo io li lasciarsi uk 48 e se ci
lasciasse anche il resto del mio corpo
capito dove mentre la chiave porca
[ __ ] il gesto del corpo sono usciti
sono scesi è uscito anche il resto del
mio corpo stranamente sta cosa è una
novità proprio cazzo salve pensavo che
avesse una roccia enorme però più o meno
è la stessa cosa
buongiorno e che cosa livello e pieno di
mostri ancora non lo dovete spiegare
perché non l'ho capito qualcuno che sta
dormendo qua dentro che cazzo è chi sei
tu ti senti prozio stai calmo perché ti
arriva una ditata nell'occhio che non me
ne frega un ca
anzi un braccio razzo rega devono
combattere il fresco tizio io devo
prenderla a biciclettate nell'occhio
credo mi piace il mio braccio
nell'occhio di loch e comoda eccolo il
perfetto ci ho messo mezz'ora per
finirlo ma ho vinto layout of the box
l'ho detto malissimo ma non importa
grado sexy bay si può cadere perfetto
non è stato guadagnato anche un'ascia
questa roba non sei guidare sta cosa no
perché ho paura di quello che fai due
te lo dico a prescindere troppo allora
merda può cadere
no no no bravo così
non è mai successo che ho vinto a primo
tentativo mai si divertono contenti loro
che mi osserva il che sopravviene ondata
di palloni fantastico una cosa più
letale di questo l'avevo mai vista mai
vista perché sono morto di per notte
allora io ho una sedia merda
avevo una sedia uscirà presto livello si
il tavolo il tavolo perché ho catturato
una katana adesso il milan non sono
arrivato tutto intero ma ho vinto
l'importante questo poi ways to die che
bella questa mi piace
accidenti cookies incidente con i
biscotti incidente che il biscottino
bellissimo quanto cazzo ci posso mai
godere a è una casa al suicidio suicidio
vogliamo che suicidi vera dover saltare
ma ma chi è che sta saltando la perfetta
grande dame meteo meteorite che cazzo
oddio papa guarda guarda
hai visto papa riunione in famiglia e
diarrea esplosiva e la di arresto si ami
mi mancava ma tanto esplosiva mi dicono
giustissimo fantastico land anche un
bellissimo che vendola prende la palla o
dio ma che cazzo di cosa pi che ho fatto
ma lei basta questo modo di fare non ho
capito che sono troppo salve ne pensa
del mio culo è di suo gradimento
prossimo lei tor che cazzo hai così
muletto no non ci voglio che rinnova
questa una [ __ ] simulator suo ep il
ragazzo sta cosa mi mancava giuro
salve york perfetto mimì mi fa piacere
che ti stai divertendo anche tu
divertiti signorini portati per caso a
casa perché vorrei avere una rosa
menchov e non detto reis i secondi per
sopravvivere
cos'è che tu mi stai dicendo che non ce
la faccio il 13 secondi mani pi in giro
che mi frega un cazzo che ti è stato
dato poi qualcosa indiana muovi il culo
ma non è possibile perché mi manca una
scarpa cazzo cazzo è caduto al rallenty
bellissima ana si si eh sì che culo ceku
loro tornambè quali al contrario foto
rana incontrarono a questa diffusissima
cazzo bagno by yoox è il primo a vincere
no mi dispiace luca è invece ma crollato
è riuscita a vincere lui porca ladro non
è possibile oltre qualsiasi con la paga
mista in cui lo sto bambino se volta ho
vinto io
non può fare tutto ciò che sa se sei
triste cazzo è sta roba prima puoi stare
morto per il resto della mia foto non ce
la fai a staccarti lamento bene dà
fastidio lurido pezzente allora devi
morire atrocemente porcata non riesco
uccidono perché cazzo ecco perché poi
salutavi superman ii degli orfani no va
beh questa è tragico a uccidere la mia
famiglia
il primo primo uk che hanno mancato
giustamente porta ladra non è possibile
ok io sono potresti tagliarmi un po più
di legna tagliate lo so la stronza ecco
bravo ma aa a aa a aa [ __ ] aicraft
sguardo fra cos'è sta roba è una nota
però sentii prenditi la spada di eco
cos'era sta roba ragazzo che pronuncia
care se riesco tipo dove dov'è il tasto
eco perfetto se riesco fa vj quiz da
qualche parte non perché tipo la vj quiz
sui video cos'è sta cosa fa vigenza del
grande grazie dio istruzioni schiaccia
il pulsante bianco giusto perfetto
domanda numero 1 quale fu il primo gioco
nel buio che fece lander man la sapeva
beh sono troppo bravo nella quarta
puntata di just dance la gamma di
famiglia è sexy però pelosa secondo voi
è una gamba che pelosa per caso no e
ovviamente sexyssima quindi direi la
seconda mandata in quell'episodio di
auto si incontra l'uomo mangia hamburger
ecco terzo episodio domanda fa vj ha mai
registra cazzo sta gamba
non riesco andare avanti a [ __ ]
allora io e te dobbiamo fare una
chiacchierata ok io sono a testa in giù
tu sei una gamba non tartassa armi le
palle che hai domande quattro famiglie
ma perché sono a testa in giù
pochi genoa ma il registrato episodi
della stoffa snow sapevo porca [ __ ]
perché effettivamente il gol e gis lato
però non l'ho pubblicato ogni pensavo
fosse nome invece ne sapri lui vi vengo
salisse al bambino di degrado non
sfuggiranno di per c'erano mi chiamo
questo lui è un fan dagli albori proprio
genio di onestà arrivare al 3 st
arrivare alla long zheng affanculo
l'ho preso dc dove la nutella
ecco perfetto complimente compitato il
testo fa vigente il migliore grazie mi
sento il migliore sei un miliardo di
cose anche in più di me purtroppo vj
addio cos'è sta cosa lo faccia senza
poco proprio per ci riesco magone gli
applausi voglio gli applausi giuro
no mai bello da un dio no no no sono
staccati per l'amor di dio strati al
pizzi dai non ci credo non ci posso
credere che non ci posso credere
a seguire via fottute medaglie dopo
questo tutte portante che ci sia
riuscito anche ragazzi e parte questo
volevo complimentarmi con tutti quelli
che hanno fatto i livelli miei di oggi è
solvente anche con chi ha fatto qui
perché cazzola epico ragazzi cosa solito
servizio è piaciuto stato commento mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook e come
ogni video trovate una descrizione se ne
vorresti discrete mi ci vediamo al
prossimo vito bene ragazzi